if you for a moment believe that Donald
Trump's authoritarian tendencies were
all fun and games it has just become
very very real as Donald Trump is now
publicly threatening to withhold money
from Michigan if they decide to vote by
mail and also threatening the state of
Nevada over vote-by-mail so in the last
three to four weeks as coronavirus has
been raging vote-by-mail logically has
become a really big deal when we think
about we've got a presidential election
we have 35 Senate elections in November
when we think about people voting when
we think about voter disenfranchisement
we immediately talk about vote-by-mail
and that's been a growing conversation
for the last month or so Donald Trump
doesn't want you to vote by mail because
he knows that if more people vote it's
very very bad for him that's it's plain
and simple I mean we we can go into more
about it but that's the story Trump
knows more people voting is not good for
him in November he sees the polls and he
knows he needs any voter suppression
tactic he can get
he has couched it as vote-by-mail makes
fraud easier this is something we've
debunked 250 million ballots have been
cast by mail in the last 20 years on
average there are seven or eight
individual issues of vote by mail fraud
per year that's not seven or eight
percent that's not seven or eight per
state that's seven or eight issues per
year nationally with absentee ballots it
is statistically as close to zero as you
can get well Donald Trump is now
becoming an authoritarian nightmare that
we always feared he would be when it
comes to this issue tweeting yesterday
quote Michigan sends absentee ballot
applications to seven point seven
million people ahead of primaries and
the general election this was done
illegally and without authorization by a
rogue Secretary of State I will ask to
hold up funding to Michigan if they want
to go down this voter fraud path now
there's a couple really important things
to understand here one is in the tweet
Trump says Michigan is doing something
illegal
by sending absentee ballot applications
earlier in the day Trump tweeted
Michigan's doing something
illegal by sending people absentee
ballots now that's not what Michigan is
doing and the michigan governor
corrected him Trump deleted the tweet
replaced it with an identical identical
one that says it's illegal to send
everybody an absentee ballot application
why do we care about that detail the
reason we care about it is because of
the rules that Michigan has now I really
want to be very clear about this there
would not be anything illegal in the way
Trump is claiming about sending
everybody an absentee ballot but it
would go away go against Michigan's
established rules for absentee ballots
the rules are you need to request one
you can't just be sent an absentee
ballot so importantly Michigan is
sending everybody an application for an
absentee ballot they want to vote in
person presumably but we as far as the
plan is right now they would still be
able to do it if they don't want to vote
in person they can submit their request
for an absentee ballot and they would be
sent one there is nothing illegal about
that now Caylee Mackin Annie Trump's
press secretary was asked multiple times
during yesterday's press briefing Trump
used the word illegal what exactly is
the law that's being broken she said go
talk to the Trump campaign which of
course makes absolutely no sense at all
it's not just Michigan where Donald
Trump is doing this Trump also tweeting
about Nevada quote state of Nevada
thinks that they can send out illegal
vote-by-mail ballots creating a voter
fraud scenario for the state and the US
they can't if they do I think I can hold
up funds to the state sorry but you must
not cheat in elections this is not
cheating okay
this is a ruse and Donald Trump is
creating a virulent SiC army of ignorant
trumpets who are just repeating these
talking points without even
understanding them it's illegal to do
this vote by mail is a fraud I really
need people to understand the primary
crux of this story we have states rights
in this country listen to me sounding
like a conservative Trump touts
federalism better
means states rights federalism means
anything that the federal government
doesn't specifically have a duty to do
the power to do it is by default the
power of the states to decide for
themselves
we don't have one federal election in
the United States for president we have
a bunch of states each runs their own
election that's the Constitution that's
federalism there is nothing here that
would allow the federal government to
dictate how a state runs their election
there now if you have truly a
constitutional issue of
disenfranchisement or something like
that you might see a case be appealed
all the way to the Supreme Court but
this is Trump's wannabe dictator coming
out Michigan allows for absentee voting
for any reason ever since 2018 that
passed sixty-six over the sixty-six
percent majority it's in the state
constitution this is federalism this is
the law Michigan is having major flood
issues right now Trump is essentially
threatening people's lives by saying I
won't send you money if you do vote by
mail and that is of course a decision
that Michigan is one hundred percent
allowed to make outside the United
States
they are watching this in horror I got
an email from a viewer in Europe saying
David isn't this fascism Trump is
attacking the sovereignty of a state
voting system that is enshrined in
federalism they are allowed to make
decisions about how they will vote what
is happening to the United States I wish
I could tell you it is a tragedy it is a
nightmare and I hate to say it but once
again I don't know that Trump will be
held accountable for these threats in
any way other than other than if we vote
him out in November real quick I want to
tell you about our sponsor magic spoon
who have done something awesome they've
taken all of our favorite sugary
childhood cereals that we know we
shouldn't eat anymore and turn them into
something you can actually feel good
about eating as an adult there's four
flavors cocoa fruity frosted and
blueberry they taste great they're
crunchy they're sweet like you would
expect this type of cereal to be but
it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only three net
carbs 12 grams of protein
it's sugar-free gluten-free grain free
soy free once our team tried magic spoon
for the first time we actually ended up
emailing magic spoon back and saying can
you send us more boxes send more samples
they've been a big hit with David Pakman
show staffers and magic spoon knows how
delicious their cereal is because if you
don't like it they'll refund all of your
money no questions asked and you'll get
free shipping when you go to magic spoon
dot-com slash Pakman and use the code
Pakman that's PA que ma N